nate is with us in Pennsylvania a night
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
Rachel our help how are you guys doing
great what's up hey so my question is
I'm a new Dave Ramsey type of learner I
just jumped on board not too long ago
and I'm currently kind of in the process
of moving my girlfriend to jump on with
me you know the name Dave Ramsey in my
house
right now as a cuss word but the good
news Rachel's name isn't a [ __ ] or yet
great job well do the sweet and sour
here okay exactly and see the nice thing
about the situation is I'm currently out
of debt and she's got some debt and she
graduates from her master's degree here
in the next three weeks awesome and I
yeah I'm super excited for her what's
her gran and we she's getting her degree
in clinical mental health therapy kind
of like dr. D a little bit yeah good
very good yeah
so she has some student loans and I was
just so close to convincing her to start
paying some of that off as soon as she
graduates but she just recently got laid
off and I am a little bit worried that
that might deter a little bit from you
know working at her student loans like I
said I I don't want to pressure her to
start paying off on any of those while
she's being laid off agreed but I also
want her to be motivated to know that
whenever she does get work again that we
can you know convince her to work work
towards those student loans as quickly
as possible this guys what's your
question name I guess my question is
what what can I do to keep her motivated
I know she's been very down on the dumps
with the layoffs and she feels like
she's kind of behind on the ball and she
was ready to go and now she feels like
she's kind of delaying the process but
maybe just the motivational advice as to
what we should do moving forward with
her situation
sure woman whoever comes to couples and
money we kind of have a pretty hard line
in the sand that
when you're not married it's two
separate entities so you guys are
running in two separate lines it's your
debt it's her debt there's no we in the
mix with the money situation so keeping
it kind of black and white but we found
that's the wisest route to go and then
once you do get married everything's
combined whether it's income debt all
the above so I would say being careful
that those boundaries are in place
because we've heard horror stories not
this is gonna happen to you guys
but of people breaking up and you've
spent you know 20 grams of your own
money to pay off her debt or something
like that so making the boundaries very
very sharp and I think for you guys I
think it's a great conversation and we
encourage people who are dating right
now like dream together and say hey if
we want a future together like what what
is our life want to look like how do we
want to get on the same page we want as
much as the value system can be aligned
the easier marriage is going to be and
specifically around money and I think
just you know encouraging her right now
she's not in a great spot like you're
saying so I'm thankful you're
acknowledging that because it's not like
she has a ton of money coming in and
she's just blowing it and not paying off
the debt but to say hey here's the value
system of where I want eventually our
life to look like together and getting
on the same page there now just to be
really really clear don't you pay her
debt this is you just walking with
somebody you care about and you're
coaching them you're encouraging them
even holding them accountable for their
own good that kind of a thing and that's
the route I would go and then just you
know continue to talk about not what to
do but why she should do it and the why
and but you're right today well she's
laid off she doesn't need to do anything
she sees a pile of cash and survive and
pay her bills and that kind of stuff and
we'll pay on the student loans when she
gets back employed and she will be in
the summer not a big deal you're gonna
get there this is the Dave Ramsey show